this video was made possible by
curiosity stream watch the companion
video to this
plus tons of other exclusive videos by
setting up the curiosity stream nebula
bundle deal
currently on sale for an unbelievable
dollar a month at curiositystream.com
wendover airlines are pragmatic
each inherently is a sizable
organization
as a degree of scale is necessary due to
the massive capital costs needed to
quite literally get a plane off the
ground
there are no mom and pop airlines
therefore airlines have the resources to
analyze choices to a
far greater level of detail than most
businesses
any decision that we the public see has
passed through such a level of review
such a level of scrutiny that it must
mean
something airlines typically don't make
emotional
informal or off-the-cuff decisions
therefore
it's odd how much airlines care about
climate change
because from a theoretical perspective
they shouldn't it doesn't currently make
sense
for airlines to care about climate
change
of course from a moral perspective it
does but businesses
traditionally and theoretically don't
value morality
higher than profit that's the role of
nonprofits
the organizational structure designed to
value social impact
first and foremost for-profit businesses
in the traditional sense are designed
for
profit therefore properly managed
they do what generates the most profit
and for airlines
right now what enables that is to not
care about
climate change carbon doesn't have a
cost for airlines
with a few exceptions emitting more
carbon does not cost the airlines
anything
but it enables them to make more profit
so the theoretically correct thing for
airlines to do
is to emit the amount of carbon that
enables them to generate the most profit
regardless of environmental consequences
some say airlines care about climate
change for public relations
and they're right but only to an extent
airlines clearly posture is caring about
their carbon footprint because consumers
increasingly care about
their carbon footprint so being viewed
as a greener airline
translates to being a more desirable
choice for consumers who
unlike for-profit businesses do care
about what's morally right
to an extent however net carbon zero is
expensive
biofuel development is expensive
sustainable aircraft development is
expensive
all more expensive than would make sense
if airlines and aircraft developers
exclusively cared about pr so
the reason why airlines are starting to
care about climate change
is because they're terrified of the r
word regulation it started already
in france the national assembly has
passed a bill that would ban short-haul
flights on routes that could be traveled
in two and a half hours or less by train
here's the worst thing for airlines
measures like this
make absolute perfect sense
with airports located away from city
centers security lines less reliable
departure times and more
no journey that would take two and a
half hours by train could reasonably and
reliably be accomplished faster
by plane the bill would still allow the
shorter flights to operate for the
purposes of connections to longer haul
flights
but passengers just couldn't book the
short flights by themselves
so there's no real downside there's the
massive upside of shifting travelers
onto trains
which in the case of france emits 77
times less carbon per passenger
on journeys of this length while this
bill faces an uphill battle as it needs
to pass through the more conservative
french senate before enactment
it's no wonder why similar measures have
been seriously considered or implemented
in the belgian region of wallonia
austria the netherlands and by countless
employers globally
the problem for airlines is that they
just don't have any good arguments
against regulations like these a move
away from the shortest tall
most replaceable flights will be the
start but it won't
end as one of the more carbon intensive
industries
airlines will face increasing regulatory
barriers to their operations
unless of course flying becomes
less carbon intensive
flying must happen in many cases
governments will not ban flying full
stop
governments will not heavily restrict
flying but governments will make it so
that the externality
the carbon footprint is priced in into
the cost of flying
that is governments will create
structures in which greener flying
is cheaper flying with for example hefty
carbon taxes so why airlines care about
climate change
is because airlines are pragmatic and
it's quickly
and increasingly becoming the case that
competitiveness as
companies is linked to how green they
are biofuels engine efficiency
improvements
carbon offsetting these things all help
but there are incremental changes that
can only take flying from being
incredibly carbon intense to very carbon
intense
however there is one solution that can
actually realistically turn flying into
a somewhat
sustainable method of transport electric
aircraft now here's the thing
electric aircraft are no massive
innovation
they existed in 1973 when the mbe-1
became the first to fly with a human
crew
they existed in 2015 when the solar
impulse 2 circumnavigated the world
exclusively on solar power
and they existed in 2020 when the
pepistral vellus electro
became the first commercially available
type-rated electric-powered
aircraft there's not a whole lot
technologically that
has or is preventing electric aircraft
from existing
what is is the business case
batteries are just more expensive and
less energy dense than fuel
so with carbon emissions always having
been free for airlines
it just always made sense to use
petroleum-based fuel
aircraft development is an unbelievably
expensive endeavor
and getting an aircraft certified for
commercial use using a new type of motor
is just all that much more so it never
made sense for a manufacturer to go
through all that for an aircraft that
didn't have
a strong business case now however
for the first time ever a strong
hypothesis of a business case has
developed
and if it works we will see the most
dramatic shift in how commercial
aircraft work
in generations electric aircraft
inherently have constraints while much
progress has been made in the past
decade to bring down the price of
batteries
and they now cost one tenth as much per
kilowatt hour compared to a decade ago
less has been done to increase battery
energy density
that is the amount of electricity stored
per pound
or kilogram that's because with electric
vehicles
the primary novel application weight
doesn't matter
that much it's easier to increase range
by bringing down cost and putting more
batteries in
than improving their energy density it's
different
with aircraft the lighter they are the
further they can fly
so there are diminishing returns in
adding additional batteries since doing
so means one needs to add even more
batteries to provide the energy to carry
the weight of those batteries
and so on and so forth also for now
all viable electric aircraft are
propeller driven specifically because it
would be far more costly to develop an
electric jet
engine and the time savings it would
offer on the short range flights that
electric aircraft would be capable of
completing
would be negligible so airlines need to
find
a use case for short-range slow
electric aircraft conveniently
it already exists from their denver
colorado hub
united airlines flies to 16 destinations
less than 250 miles or 400 kilometers
away
in particular in this case many of these
destinations such as montrose aspen
eagle county and hayden
are high yield and high frequency
despite their close distance
since they connect tourists to popular
ski towns in the case of wiedero
a norwegian regional airline 19 of their
47 overall destinations
are within 250 miles of their tromso hub
and a strong majority of their routes
are over distances less than this then
there are airlines like cape air who do
not fly a single route
over 250 miles in length the use case
for electric aircraft already exists
because airlines like cape air already
found it just not yet using
electric aircraft they fly from large
hubs to small destinations on 9-seat
propeller aircraft
and partner with mainline airlines to
offer connecting itineraries
for them the electric aircraft range
constraints don't matter
since all their routes are so short and
therefore the speed constraints
don't either when cape air flies from
martha's vineyard to new york jfk
on the propeller driven cessna 402 the
flight takes an average of 70 minutes
whereas delta flying the same route
using a jet crj 200
takes 45 when cape air flies from
nantucket to boston logan airport
they take 39 minutes whereas jetblue on
their e190 aircraft
takes 28. those extra 11 or 25 minutes
are negligible in the overall travel
experience especially considering that
cape air's boarding times
with nine passengers are certainly
quicker than with delta's 50 passengers
or jet blues 100. so not only could
electric aircraft seamlessly replace all
of cape air's flights
but they could also take over some of
delta jetblue united or other larger
airlines as routes without a negative
impact to overall trip
time so the use case exists passengers
would accept the switch
but what do electric aircraft do for
airlines aside from enabling a
continuation of operations in the face
of increasing regulation
a very specific answer for this exists
thanks to
one short document this
is the u.s department of
transportation's order reselecting
airline document for their essential air
service subsidized flights from boston
logan airport to augusta
and rocklin maine you see the us
government
subsidizes routes to these small remote
communities across the country
in order to improve connectivity and
economic opportunity for
these areas as it's the u.s taxpayer
funding these programs
the bids from airlines to operate these
routes are a matter of public record
providing a truly unique glimpse into
accurate operating costs for a single
airline route
while they competed against boutique air
cave air ended up winning the bid
so they now operate the route to
rockland maine
in exchange they received a subsidy of 2
million 218
126 dollars for their first year 2018 to
ramping up to 2 million 495 090
by their fourth rockland is a tourist
hotspot in the summer
but it returns to a quieter state for
the rest of the year so the airline's
obligations for flight frequency
varies by the season anywhere between
three daily round-trip flights in winter
to six in the summer all in all though
they're obligated to operate some 1
365 flights annually representing 12
285 total available passenger seats in
each
direction according to cape air's
estimates this round should cost some
three million three hundred fifty
thousand
seven hundred and forty six dollars a
year to operate they estimated some
fifteen thousand one hundred and twenty
two total passengers would fly
but publicly available data shows that
only 6733 boarded their planes in
rockland in 2019
assuming it's roughly the same in the
other direction as one would expect
that means they saw only 13 466 total
passengers representing a 54.8 percent
load factor
selling tickets for an average of 83
dollars the airline likely therefore
brought in 1 million 117
678 in passenger revenue which
combined with her 2 million 247 721 year
2 subsidy
means they earned some 3 million 365 399
in revenue subtracting their annual cost
estimates
that means they only turned
and 14 three dollars in profit or a
dollar
and nine cents worth per passenger
this is how tight airline profit margins
can be but what would they be if this
route was operated by
an electric airplane well to start
fuel costs would be almost entirely
eliminated
electricity isn't free but its costs are
so low compared to fuel
that it essentially becomes a non-factor
electricity can also be converted
into a capital cost instead of ongoing
cost through investing in solar or wind
energy generation
which cape air has hinted at doing so
this 844 0002 dollars in annual fuel
costs
we can consider it for all intents and
purposes
eliminated other costs would go up
cape air budgets 269 903 dollars per
year on ownership costs
meaning the amortized prorated cost of
owning their
aircraft while details are not known and
so an accurate estimate would be
impossible
there's no world in which a new electric
aircraft is cheaper than the
mass-produced
long-proven cessna 402. it wouldn't be
unreasonable to expect that ownership
costs would
say double then there are the
maintenance costs
these would be significantly lower than
with traditional internal combustion
driven aircraft
the thing is electric motors are just so
simple they have exactly one moving part
the shaft electric vehicles typically
never require motor maintenance
as there's really just nothing that can
break or wear down within their
lifetimes
the same principle will apply to
electric airplanes and so much of the
maintenance work
aircraft require currently is on their
engines
while it's very tough to know with any
confidence how this will play out in
reality with planes that don't yet exist
there's a world in which aircraft
maintenance would cost a fraction
as much overall these three factors
combined
a near total elimination of fuel costs a
dramatic increase in ownership costs
and a dramatic decrease in maintenance
costs track with cape airs estimates
for a 40 reduction in operating
costs that is enormous
under rockland routes assuming no change
in revenue that would take one dollar
and nine cents in per passenger profit
and turn it
into 100.62 cents
a number so dramatically different that
it doesn't even
sound correct this would immediately
turn cape air
into the highest operating margin
airline in the world
full stop this is why the future of
short haul flying
is inevitably electric this is why
in 2019 cape air became the first
commercial customer to order
the alice a nine passenger electric
aircraft developed by startup aircraft
manufacturer
aviation it will be able to fly each and
every one of the airline's routes
round-trip
without charging there are certainly no
guarantees that the atlas will see the
light of day
aircraft development is an incredibly
costly risky and long process that can
spell failure for even the strongest
concepts
but everything so far suggests that
aviation
has just as much a shot at success as
all the other players that have entered
this race while cape air may be
pioneering the use of these aircraft in
the commercial context
as they have the advantage of a
pre-existing route network and business
strategy that are conducive to their use
the release of such aircraft will
fundamentally break a
long-held truth about aviation shorehaul
flying
is currently more expensive per mile
than long-haul flying
due to the high fixed costs involved
with the ground operations
at each airport however with electric
aircraft available
exclusively on shorter routes at least
in the near future
there's a reality in which it's cheaper
per mile to fly 200 miles
than 2 000 miles that will shift
airlines focus
to more regional route networks and
connect communities that previously were
too small to make economic sense for
airlines
in short not only will electric aircraft
allow airlines to continue to operate
short haul as regulations ramp
up but it will allow them to increase it
in a sustainable
profitable way the future of flying
is inevitably electric because the
business case
is just too strong to ignore
plenty of progress has already been made
to make electric flying a reality
and as much as i'd like to tell you in
detail about the specific electric
aircraft that you might fly in a matter
of years
and how they work there just isn't the
time in this
video the youtube algorithm has just
decided that 15 to 20 minutes is our
sweet spot for video length
and if we stray from that the videos
don't perform well
conveniently though nebula doesn't have
an algorithm
so i created a companion video to this
about that topic
and put it there nebulous subscribers
can watch that
our regular videos early and ad-free
other exclusive companion videos and
extended cuts
and our big-budget nebula originals of
which we have plenty and we have our
biggest one yet
in post-production right now making that
even better
you can get access to nebula through the
bundle deal with curiosity stream which
is on sale for father's day at its
lowest ever pricing of
under one dollar per month of course by
signing up through them
you also get access to their massive
super interesting library of non-fiction
documentaries and shows
for example and i've recommended this
before because it's so good you could
watch
china's last little train about the
narrow gauge railway that connects one
of china's most
isolated regions altogether this bundle
provides a massive amount of stuff that
you'll actually watch
and it comes at an absurdly low price
again
the current father's day sale is the
lowest their prices have ever been
just under one dollar a month so there
has never been a better time to sign up
at curiositystream.comwendover
and best of all you'll be helping all
these independent creators stay
independent while you're at it